Ще вісім місяців тому Оксана здивувалася б, якби дізналася,
що буде їздити щоранку на роботу з Дармштадта у Франкфурт поїздом компанії Deutsche Bahn.
І ще більше здивувалася б, якби дізналася, що в цій компанії і працюватиме -
на франкфуртському вокзалі, в бюро з працевлаштування, куди приходять здебільшого іноземці -
такі ж, як і вона. Оксана родом із Києва. У перші дні війни вона знайшла притулок у Німеччині.
Це була нелегка поїздка. Достатньо нелегка, але щойно ми перетнули кордон Німеччини,
нам допомогли, нас провели, нам показали, нас зустріли і, чесно кажучи, заспокоїли.
Тепер Оксана працює на вокзалі у Франкфурті і допомагає здобути впевненість та спокій тим,
хто пройшов цей шлях після неї.
У кожного з нас, новоприбулих, є дуже великий страх і нерозуміння ситуації, що відбувається…
Коли люди приходять і чують, що до них звертаються знайомою для них мовою, чи російською, чи українською,
вони трохи розслабляються, вони можуть спокійно обговорювати теми.
Вони можуть розкритися як професіонали, вони можуть розкритися як люди.
Варіантів працевлаштування на німецькій залізниці достатньо.
Компанія Deutsche Bahn - один з найбільших роботодавців Німеччини.
У списку вакансій - приблизно 500 спеціальностей.
І три такі центри з працевлаштування - у Франкфурті, Берліні та Лейпцигу -
відкрили кілька місяців тому саме з розрахунку на українських біженців.
З-поміж українських біженців, які залишили країну з початку війни,
ми вже змогли взяти на роботу 46 людей різних професій.
Наприклад, зараз нам потрібні співробітники для сфери громадського харчування у поїздах, робітники та електрики.
Але ми також шукаємо нових співробітників у галузі продажів. Двері широко відчинені.
Про те, наскільки справні українці в роботі, співробітники центру оцінюють, зокрема, і завдяки Оксані.
Я просто захоплений Оксаною - її амбіціями, внеском, який вона робить, і силою, яку вона має.
А також тим, що за дуже короткий час перебування в Німеччині вона так багато чого навчилася
і вже добре нас розуміє.
Оксана не тільки розуміє нову для себе мову, а й цілком успішно використовує її в роботі.
Адже вся документація сотень запропонованих професій - німецькою.
Так, ці позиції мають німецькі назви, їхній опис також німецькою.
І завдяки інтенсивному курсу, який також допоміг мені пройти Deutsche Bahn,
я все це розумію, приймаю і можу вже брати участь у консультаціях.
Однак не всі біженці настільки цілеспрямовані, як Оксана,
і не всі володіють спеціальностями, затребуваними на залізниці.
Саме тому тут також приймають фахівці з федеральної агенції з працевлаштування.
Вони пропонують вже не сотні вакансій, а десятки тисяч.
У нас дуже великі можливості для підтримки та консультацій людей.
Ми тут саме тому, що добре доповнюємо пропозиції роботи Deutsche Bahn,
оскільки можемо також консультувати з інших питань та надавати інші вакансії.
Вже понад місяць бюро з працевлаштування Deutsche Bahn
відкрито не лише для українських біженців, а й для всіх, хто шукає роботу.
Шахаб Хан родом із Пакистану. Він хотів би влаштуватися провідником чи офіціантом вагона-ресторану.
Я звернувся сюди, до DB Jobwelt, тому що співробітники центру дуже доброзичливі та готові прийти на допомогу.
І якщо ви не знаєте, як знайти роботу в Німеччині, тут вам можуть допомогти.
Щодо Оксани, то роботу до душі в компанії Deutsche Bahn вона вже знайшла.
І сподівається, що Німеччина стане її новим домом та місцем, де для неї відкриються нові професійні горизонти.